give us the financial freedom now really
because i'm on two grand on the passive
income
just when i thought this deal couldn't
get any better hey what's up my name is
samuel leeds right now i'm standing
outside of property in barnsley
now look i've been investing in property
now for 12 years and if i could sum up
everything i know about investing in
property i'd say this
buy low rent high with a property
manager
nearby now the man who bought this
property is one of my students he bought
it very low
he's about to rent it real high and i
thought i'd show you what's going on
the landlord behind the house so you can
learn how you can do the exact same
thing too
don't forget to subscribe smash the like
button drop a comment below
let me show you around
you're the owner of the house yeah good
to see you what was this and what's
going on here
yeah so it's a three-bedroom terrace
this was the lounge originally
um so in order to meet the fire
regulations for hmo
you need to have a fire exit at both
entrances so
from the back door yeah so we wanted to
put this wall in so that people could
get through the
into the front door um without any
danger of the fire or anything so we put
the stud wall in
this room is nine foot by twelve so it's
still a double room
and uh yeah so this was so before you'd
open up the door you just have a big
open space
yeah now you've created a corridor and a
room yeah and presumably this is not
going to be a sitting room
no that's right so this is going to be a
bedroom as you can see we've got the
the bases in already and um yeah so
we've got someone coming in to
to rent this out in a couple of weeks
time so this is going to be a 4-bed hmo
yeah you bought it low yes you're ready
66 000. and it's in a good area
yeah it's an ace it's 250 yards from the
town center
right they're so handy for anybody who
wants to walk in for work or anything
so you bought it for 66 000. yeah um i'm
gonna
ask for the rest of the figures later
but let's have a look around and see
what else we've got yeah so nice fire
doors as well
yeah so those are the cottage types i
thought there was a facebook for 40 quid
these were forty founders yeah the brand
new they were a reefer
door nice uh proper fd30 which is the
fire eggs 30 minute fire doors
which means if there's a fire it will
take 30 minutes for the fire to get
through right yeah
if you've got people if you've got lots
of people in the house it's more likely
that a hazard could happen it's more
like
there could be a fire so you need it to
be safe the last thing you want is
is um is you know a fire to happen and
you you wouldn't be able to live would
you
yeah that's right if you hadn't taken
precaution but this
doesn't need a license no that's right
any anything that's four people
uh doesn't need a license no license no
planning
nothing like that but you're just taking
extra precaution to make sure that
you're a good landlord
yeah we want to make sure that if the
council come round they're happy with
the house yeah
but they won't come around really no
they weren't but you're just being a
good landlord
all right show us around yeah so again
we're on fire doors with the clothes
in here and this is going to be the
dining room lounge for the hmo
nice nice good yeah i like this it's so
light and open it feels like i'm really
high up
yeah it's it's a good property and it
you know it's a good area close to town
so it's
i'm wondering how you got it so cheap 66
grand it sounds
really loud well it was just one that i
in essence i
i've been looking at samuel's book and
prior to
buying this one i was buying them for
double the amount
um but when i bought this i knew i was
looking for something that was low cost
that i could refurb and then this one's
going to rent for 1500
a month so i'm actually getting the same
profit as
i've got in this one as the one i paid
double the amount for
wow and that's just because of samuel
[ __ ] youtubes and training really
and that's buy low rent higher yeah
exactly yeah and also you've not spent a
fortune once it looks like you have
but but you've furnished it it's really
nice i know you've not spent a fortune
5 40 quid how much was that stood wall
yeah so the builder charged me six
hundred quid
very nice for the wall and the election
kitchen
so 500 pounds off facebook and listen
when you're saying all these figures
like the kitchen was 500 quid
i don't want my viewers to think that's
just the price of a kitchen because it's
not yeah
you know you've done really really well
you've got good you've got good you
connected well to good people you've
searched well um you've obviously had to
pay for someone to fit it as well right
yeah so so my builder fitting it for 650
for the whole kitchen
right and 650 for the whole bathroom so
the entire kitchen cost you just over a
grand
yeah very very good yeah the reason
these kind of locks are really important
for hmos which is what this is going to
be
is because you can't take that you can't
take the key out there is no kid
these are called thumbnail locks because
imagine if someone locked the door
took the key out left the key somewhere
and then there was a fire
and you're trying to get out but you
can't find the kit you're stuffed
so if it's a hmong you've got multiple
people in the property they require
thump uh uh what they've got thumb turn
yeah thumb turn thumb turn locks
um you know so it's just a little tip if
you're getting a hmo
get thumbs up but i actually think thumb
turn locks are really practical anyway
so
yeah absolutely yeah they were 30 quid a
pizza 30 quid
so it's not off amazon not expensive
yeah
so good for a barbecue out here oh i
love
it it's all right isn't it really nice
interesting question how much rent would
you get as a single letter he's drinking
about 500.
so they said that because the market's
so hot in barnsley at the moment this
would go 600 if it was btl
right so you can rent it out for 600 as
a single lap
or 1500 as a hmo obviously you've got to
pay the bills
yeah so you're going to be paying what
what the bill is going to be you reckon
on this
um so about 700 all in 700 council tax
that sounds like a lot you know yeah so
council tax is 140.
and the electric and gas is five pounds
a day that's like 150.
yeah um and then you've got the mortgage
200. okay that's right you're including
the mortgage yeah that's right
oh my goodness you need to switch
supplier bro yeah yeah yeah if you
include the mortgage 700
yeah makes sense and general rule of
thumb what i say in my book
is the rent for a hmo like this the rent
you can pretty much just say half of it
is going to be gone yeah
on mortgage gas council tax wi-fi bills
management
and then the other half's probably going
to be profit which is about about right
on this
yes how much did you pay for everything
entire refurb and furnishings
yeah so the refurb was 12 grand that was
for all the
re-clustering and building work kitchen
bathroom
and the furniture and everything else
including roofing and whatever you was
three grand very good oh yeah 15 total
you didn't spend a lot of furniture
there but it looks nice yeah
how much was this table 70 quid on
facebook for the table and the
so you really shopped around and well
the wife's really good at finding stuff
on facebook so she had that job
great love it yeah and the beds we got
from a company off facebook new ones for
160 a bed
so you bought it for 66 you spent 15 on
it including everything yeah
you're going to rent it for 1500 a month
yeah what's the end value going to be
once it's
wait it is finished so what i've had
three estate agents around two of them
valued it at 120.
and the other one valued it at 110. so
that's insane
nothing else so you're going to
presumably refinance it pour your money
out
yeah so we can refinanced at the moment
so if you've had who's refinancing it
mr bench benchmark mortgage as well
all right so let's say it's 115 yeah
if it's 115 000 you're going to get a 75
loan to value right
correct so you're going to pull out 86
yeah but you bought it for 66 and put 15
in so you're only pointing 81 yeah so
you're going to apply
all your money all of it and then you're
going to rent it for 1500
you're going to probably end up paying
how much you're going to be left with
profit after all cash flows 800 a month
after everything
very very cool and again in baltimore
book that's exactly what i predict
this is awesome mate it's changed my
life that's great man
i'm so glad because you've been involved
for a long time now yeah we i started in
2008 i bought two off plan flats
uh in sheffield for five grand of beats
and the builder gave us 10 cashback so
we
were straight in the mortgage at five
grand a piece
uh but he just not gone up in value at
all in that time so probably not 10
round a piece
i wish i'd have known your strategy
before i'd have bought two houses and
i'd been able to pull the money out by
that because now you're rather than
waiting on the capital appreciation
you're forcing the value up
yeah um which is which is really nice
how much were the carpets
they were 1800 for everything is that
including fitting
yeah okay and it was no finance oh good
so united carpets do like 60 quid a
month on it
over two years so it's it's really good
really
it's good yeah been really good yeah so
i got fed up of my my work in 2019 i
wanted to get
full-time in property yeah so i borrowed
a load of money
in 2019 and started my first renovation
right great well i think this this
project is is a little peach you know
it's awesome another thing is as well
this area
don't need a license don't need planning
permission yeah
although it isn't in an article 4 area
but you've been extra smart
because it's this area is going to be
article 4 right yeah so may the 25th the
council are bringing in
article 4 so from then you won't be able
to have a
mini hmo or start one off without
planning permission so this whole area
is going to be article four yeah
which what does it what does that mean
for people watching so it means that
you can't convert terraced houses into
hmos without planning permission after
that and they won't give planning
permission
no they don't like having so in other
words if someone watches this on youtube
and they go oh i want to do the same
thing unfortunately you can't
yeah that's right it's done but i was
saying a year ago on youtube
do this and and pete went okay and pete
did it
you can't do this anymore that's right
it's finished
pete got in before may 25th so you know
and that's the tragedy people
people sometimes just don't listen you
you've got to take action you know so
you've taken because what's going to
happen now is
article 4 is going to come in this will
have grandfather
rights yeah automatic planning
permission it will kill all the
competition off
anyone else trying to come in which is
going to mean the rents are going to be
increased
the value is going to go up it will
become a special edition because you got
in early
absolutely you know so i guess the only
thing i can say someone watching is
find an area not barnsley an area that's
not article 4 yet and there's many
yeah and we talk about this on training
and then do the same thing that you've
done p
but just in a different area like what
you've been taking advantage of the
economy taking advantage of the
situation
yeah because they say that potentially
it goes up twenty percent after article
four
hmos though yeah and it might take a
little while there could be a bottleneck
yeah but yeah absolutely because it
becomes special edition it's like if
you've got a car
and then they stop building the cars
then it becomes vintage
how much you spend on the furniture yeah
that's so the refurb and everything was
12 and the furniture and the
sofas and washers and everything's been
right three grand so this one i'll go
for 80 a week so the others are 90.
who are the tenants going to be moving
in then what's the crack so this
particular
um tenant is a building company who
are building some some work in barnsley
and they're looking for 24 rooms
uh near to the town centre and you've
got them quite lucky there then really
yeah quite fortunate and the estate
agents really good so they're 10
plus that which is probably the best you
can get on hml i think
and um and they found those tenants that
are coming in on saturday to confirm the
deal
and if they're a company it'd be really
straightforward because
one tenant you just ran into a company
so it's like a company that yeah which
is going to mean less hassle for you
which is great yes
this would be my room before i was if i
was renting this yeah
the views it's brilliant isn't it you've
got a view over at the barnes stadium
over there
yeah so so obviously if you're a bit of
a football fan
you're in business aren't you it's great
so yeah it's been
it's been a good i can't believe you got
it so cheap i know i can't believe it
it's unreal isn't it you know 66 and
then 15 in and then
you know say if it's 115 110 and still
making 30 grand profit
yeah still pulling out all your money
after all the refurb and everything
since i found your youtube and s365
which was 2019 in
2020 in march i've added free to my
portfolio since then great
so that is you know i mean it's not
freedom you know challenge
stuff but it's it's impressive stuff
you're building your cash flow but
you're also building your net worth and
you're building your portfolio
so yeah i like this house the calls are
really good
on the wednesday night oh i'm really
enjoying it yeah people are just
brilliant aren't they
just i'm just loving it and yeah i'm
loving it you know some of the stuff
that is coming out of them is just
insane yeah i mean i was helping another
lady on
365 kirsty the other day and then gemma
popped up and said she wanted to
co-source with people
so i just patched them together and for
getting on with it and that's the power
of it isn't it
absolutely i love and then 365
it's like if you want to get mentored in
property normally you might have to pay
a few grand to somebody
with a 365 you've got access to all of
the different mentors
yeah [ __ ] limited calls got the
weekly coaching calls you've got the
dfe for 95 quid a month it's awesome
you can't really support posting if
there's any deals just send it my way
out there yeah
absolutely i think it's so
powerful yeah and then and then if
people like that and
i love it and they've got a lot of value
then they can upgrade onto the academy
yeah then they get all the courses like
that they can upgrade onto the full
academy
yeah um which is where you got the
physical events so there's something for
everybody really regardless of
um you know where you're at so no i'm
loving it
365's just been a complete game changer
for me
it's good i've gone from a situation
where i was like an enthusiastic
clueless person
yeah to to being able to have access to
the best mentors in
the country so and then just being able
to deal with it that way
so there we have it folks this is a
combination between a hmo
a house in multiple occupancy where you
rent it out room by room
and a brr a buy refurbished refinance
rent property i think teach them really
well listen if you want to see more
videos like this let's show our
appreciation to pete
pete let us film around here he gets
nothing from this
so to show your appreciation to pete
please smash the like button
and we'll see if we can get this video
to over 100 likes and then i'll do
another video just like it or i'll show
you around another property investment
maybe one of mine maybe one of my
students also please do me a massive
favor and subscribe
you can subscribe right about here if
you want to see more videos like this
you can check them out here
and if you want to join our community
i'd like to invite you to the property
investors crash course where you can
come for free
on the house right here and i look
forward to seeing you and helping you do
the same